tell a novella this is yeah it's a great
idea this is your idea
yeah what's what's clear is that the
people making this really love the genre
but you're having a lot of fun with it
oh my god we're having so much fun uh
yeah telenovela is a show it's a comedy
behind the scenes of a spanish soap
opera
and i play the star of the spanish soap
opera who does not speak spanish
speaks no spanish no yeah so she's uh
everything's phonetic and
and that's kind of how i grew up i grew
up in texas i'm a texan
and um yes and every i didn't i grew up
in a latino community but i didn't speak
spanish and so i would be like
oh like that's so funny i'm sorry what
did he say yeah oh
yeah i might come up to you and just
assume um she knows how to speak spanish
you may go and
you have no idea but i've since learned
it and uh
i do speak it now but the show is so
funny because
it's uh that's we're making a telenovela
but the show's about the crazy drama and
people that make a telenovela and we
have all these amazing comedic actors
and uh it's just nice to be back in tv
you know what's interesting
is you had some experience working in
the soap opera genre you were
wrestling so i would imagine that you
would be able to
in this new show drawing your experience
working around you always hear about
soap opera divas and how there can be
people can
lose their perspective a little bit when
they're making these shows is that true
yes want to name any names
no no you wouldn't name any names no no
because you know what the people i
worked with
i worked with doug davidson christian
leblanc they were awesome but like
there's 45
characters and so some people i never
worked with but i i would come in and
out and they'd be
like this happened this morning and i
can't believe she left and he walked out
and i was like
ooh you mean people come
bitching and complaining about yes about
some actors there were some crazy ass
actors at
that time yeah people don't know that no
daytime
was it was you know was was a doggy dog
world
yeah i have what i have a rule people
ask me about show business and i say
it's 80 10 10. you see if you agree with
the sandy it's 80
of people are just fine 10 are
incredibly nice
maybe less than 10 and then 10 are
batshit crazy
yeah no i definitely i think that's
about right
no i think it's 80 is batshit crazy
really
okay no name
why don't you love me
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i call you so often
yeah i'm definitely it would be an
awesome title for this show
why don't you love me yeah with dylan
o'brien
isn't that kind of hasn't that really
been the subtitle
you should come on telenovela what part
how would i fit into
it i'd be the guy that walks in
your package is here
what am i going to play you have to rip
off your shirt a lot though yeah
yeah oh
no ratings like when you see this chest
let me tell you right now
rip a bright white light shoots out
three copper hairs uh i went a little
too far